thank you hello everyone hello internet
and Internet over there people watching
outside I am Matt Welch I am the
editor-in-chief of Reason magazine which
is a really really great job as you're
going to hear probably throughout the
course of this evening I want to thank
you for coming the reason headquarters
and watching from where ever to talk
about celebrate our 45th anniversary of
being in existence with many of the most
important people who made this all
possible sitting immediately to my left
is an incredible group of people who i
genuflect towards on a daily basis
postural who added the magazine for all
of the 1990s author of many terrific
books including the future and its
enemies and the brand new one there's
information out around called power
glamour check it out a bob pool who
still sits on the board of trustees for
recent Foundation director of policy and
educators page policy he's been there a
reason he's going to tell story in a
little bit I'm Annie klausner noted
First Amendment lawyer lawyer
extraordinaire also still sits in the
board of trustees Tibor McCann one of
the three musketeers who kept this
institution to float in the early 70s
he's associated with Chapman University
on give them a warm round of applause
start off with a web unfriendly exercise
but just so we can get a sense of the
room here how many people started
reading or becoming aware of recent
magazine just in the last couple of
years hands up please so a good thirty
percent of the room twenty-five percent
uh and the otts the dreadful aughts the
nickel sprl electric great show of hands
sewn it didn't bring anyone due to
default that's a 90s okay some posture
all friends 80s here we go the Marty
Zupan fan club here 70's look at that
and do you have nineteen sixties reason
readers in the room seriously the best
thing about working for the sitting in
my chair this magazine is meeting people
like you and hearing their stories of
when they first intersected with reason
what they thought of this weird thing in
their hands how that played into their
life as it develops so I'm just going to
start by asking these people how that
happened to them Bob let's start with
you well I was out of school rmit one
year living in Connecticut working for
an aerospace company and not knowing a
soul who was libertarian or Objectivist
and I found saw a little classified ad
in a newsletter called libert called
liberal innovator that was a sort of
occasional liver hair puppy for reason
magazine and it had a few phrases that
sounded kind of Randy and I thought wow
I gotta find out this so I sent in my
check for a subscription with something
like three dollars or four dollars for a
year that's a lot of money as a semi
aground Bingham came in the mail and it
looked very amateurish but I read it it
actually impressed me he was saying some
very strong positions things about how
SDS was was wrecking universities and
and how we really needed principles and
government was screwing everything up as
far out we didn't have internet we'd
have email I probably wrote him a letter
and said
i discovered this I'd like to know a
little more about it you know what are
you doing so forth we ended up talking
on the phone and he somehow over the
next couple of months persuaded me to
try writing an article for it I'd never
written anything for public hey I've
been Honors English in high school and
stuff but I never tried to write any
publication so actually researched and
wrote an article using the library at
sikorsky aircraft about the history of
airline regulation and why airlines
should be deregulated and he published
it this but the great thing was he
didn't tell me that the issue that it
appeared in first of all was going to be
the kind was the cover story second of
all it was the first issue that was
typeset instead of mimeograph and third
it was first it was offset printed and
so this all of a sudden this thing's
comes in the mail why the frenzied skies
on the cover in an airplane from
silhouette and it's my story as the
cover story I mean there were only four
hundred subscribers that that was a
life-changing moment this is really
something disc and this could turn out
to be something real and so over the
next year or so I wrote three or four
more articles moved to California and
met these guys we're also involved you
know with no reading the magazine and so
forth and then we things developed from
there let's talk about the crazy
Californians Manny how did you first
encounter this magazine I came through T
board because of a very unusual pathway
kpfk which is part of pacifica network
of say not a other battalions closed no
no it's very left with but very
left-wing they one night i listed a lot
of weird things and one night I was
listening kpfk I heard this guy who
sounded even more rational than what you
read there's the issue of reason it was
this guy named Tibor talking he had a
program on political philosophy and
events of the day on kpfk and they
occasionally those days that were in
hardcore they only had about 99% so you
know that I think they purged everybody
every few years just in case but Tibor I
call Tibor and introduced myself to him
I was practicing law they
mid-sized Los Angeles law firm like it's
been I just meant there had been there
some four or five years I had taught at
the inverse Chicago Law School before
they had and etc but I call Tibor we
spoken on the phone and Tibor and I
obviously are reasonably forward guy so
we hit it off very well and yeah tibor
told me about Bob and told me about
Reason magazine and so that's the
initial delivering of how it started and
how did you how did you come to be able
to educate young mr. clasper I don't
remember anything we're not in hungry
now it's okay well it was very
compliment I mean it was very flattering
to hear from Manny because I did get
this gig on kpfk now kpfk is a you know
pacifica radio which most people in the
Southern California area know as fairly
left-wing although i wouldn't say they
were like hardcore Stalinist or so they
invited me as a kind of a token to be on
the radio and lend the slightly
different tone to their you know report
or and so every week I would go down
there on thursdays and do an hour and a
half or two hours rather amateurish
commentary but it gave me some practice
and that's what Manny heard and that's
how we got going but how did you how did
you find reason eggsy all right away a
recent got in touch with me man I mean
Lanny friedlander had asked me to make a
contribution I don't want the hell to do
because I wasn't like you writing on on
anything topical so I told him that I
had written a couple of things for local
I op-ed pieces were not actually Abed
what was it was an a magazine called the
personal asst that John Haas / had
published at USC it was actually a
fairly respectable philosophy journal
and I showed that Lanny a couple of
articles are written for that journal
and he reprinted it in reason one was
and you wouldn't believe this one it's
not the kind of stuff that reason
publishes these days history of the
Apriori it was actually quite germain at
the time but but that's the way it got
going and then we gathered together in
Santa Barbara we had a very nice meeting
and Manny came up and Bob had already
moved there I thought I'd been there in
January my hands uh so we cooked up some
way of getting this thing launched you
know was really amazing I mean we were
we didn't really think of it as a big
deal like we just thought that this is
what people who care about certain
principles and issues would do well I
mean I think I think we really worried
wrote the business plan in summer of
nineteen seventy we really did have in
mind that reason magazine could become
the the libertarian counterpart of Nash
of National Review in New Republic maybe
even the Harper's in Atlantic I mean we
actually use those words in the business
plan that was the plan I mean that was
it was a long-range vision I remember my
idea was I wrote one of those
perspectives yeah yeah and my idea was
to be a little bit like commentary which
was a probably a bad idea because
commentary was all yeah print yeah no
pictures nothing not no illustrations
nothing pretty however it does did give
us something to aim you know and it
should be said when we took my he and
all this ring about landing
Friedlander's is very visionary college
student and just kind of an artistic
genius at least I as a consumer of
work that he did when I was two months
old looked like Virginia you first
stumbled upon the magazine in what
context okay so first of all people used
to ask me when I was editor really did
you start reason it was like that was at
the third grade oh but oh but um
actually my boyfriend discovered a
reason who most of you know as my
husband um we were in college and one of
the things that both of us used to like
to do was to look around the periodicals
shelves in the library and find things
to read and um I really loved this
category of magazine that you were
talking about I think magazines and I
read commentary and I read Harper's I
read The Washington Monthly um I like
them all but none of them exactly
matched my own political views which
were more libertarian I forget how I
figured out that was the name of em but
I this anthology that team or edited in
72 has something to do with it because
between between um my juniors sophomore
and junior years and hice and college
rather I worked at the art museum next
to the public library and I used to get
all these books on the public library I
was answering the phone let me give head
I read that is complementarian
alternative right so I really and it was
a response to a publisher from Chicago
Nelson Hall it sent out a flyer they
wanted to get on the way and so I knew
that when they were hungry they would
get my book and so sure enough I put
together this real good selection of
libertarian and similar articles people
like Hayek and Mises and Brandon and
everybody was in that book Murray
Rothbard and so on it was a big thing
that was a big thing yeah I still look
at amazon and occasionally pick up our a
stray copy that they have floating about
anyway so um in I really like these
magazines and in fact what I really
wanted to do when I grew up was to edit
one of these magazines but not any of
the ones that I knew about unless you
could turn them you know into a
different political view and in fit in
the februari 1981 issues Steve found it
in the library and it was the famous
love canal so today I'm proud yeah I
ever can that is and that was the first
issue of reason that we read and it
changed my life and I said I mean it
didn't really change my life because I
just started reading reason and I
thought oh when I grow up I'd like to be
editor reason fine you know that's a
really stupid ambition because first of
all Mason is in Santa Barbara and your
life is never going to take you to Santa
Barbara at least not during your working
years and and secondly you know how many
people could I mean actually was even a
dumber ambition that I knew but you know
I pic i thought that like you know t
born man and we're senior editors the
way the senior editor said like ink
magazine which I later work for or
senior editors like they were getting
but anyway so I didn't really so funny
that way I didn't really expect this
thing to come true but that was how we
discovered it Bobby you might want to
talk about the the Love Canal issue well
though that was really uh one of the
earliest investigative journalism pieces
that we did the first one was the exposé
of Cesar Chavez's Union getting using
federal grants to build the Union and
that made national television and when
we were really little we had a staff of
three at that point and Marty zupan and
I worked our butts off doing fact
checking on that article and so we sort
of learned by doing of what you have to
do to be credible pesky journal thus
love canal thing was the idea of
proposal came over the transom from the
sky Eric Zeus
we didn't know from Adam but he
presented he said I have I figured out I
found what has never been reported about
why the Love Canal thing actually
happened it was not the chemical company
was the school board that disregarded
deed restrictions blah blah blah so you
better explain what Love Canal is let's
train out to me well under the age yeah
50 don't look there's nobody here now it
was that was used was owned by I think
this was a damn ok No Oh Kirk Kirk Emma
cooked on hooker Chemical they had
disposed you know those days there
weren't any PA la serena so this was in
the 50s they dispose of chemical wastes
in it it was their property later ups
many years later the school board in
niagara falls new york condemned the
land and took it over to build a school
and the company in conceding to to have
the atlantic's procreated insisted on a
deed restriction saying there's
hazardous waste buried there do not
excavate blah blah blah blah and in the
school but and the school board signed
this full knowledge that it was there
some years later they they built things
excavating they said you couldn't use it
for the living or you know there's
certain projects dude that's right that
was a ends another digging it up digging
parts of it up and basically creating
channels for the waste to seep out into
the neighborhood by just completely
disregarding but the whole the media
when when left louis whatever her name
was the local activists of sold story to
the media that this heartless chemical
company had deceived everybody and
poisoned the neighborhood and and that's
what the national media reported and our
study been documented meticulously had
the actual deeds and all the data and so
forth and that made national television
to we were concerned when we launched
our investigative reporting series with
the cesar chavez at jose we were very
concerned we thought there was a strong
like that would get sued so we wanted to
make sure that not only was the story
accurate but every detail that was
accurate and that was we did have a
grant of money to allow us to spend some
time digging down drilling down all the
way and we had a lot of confidence when
both of those articles before they were
we run we had a we were all solid with a
solid we were all solid and we were a
complete amateurs yeah let's talk about
blows my mind as someone who's written
about the press for a long time and
participated in startups and things like
that your first paid employee was when
well we had this during the during the
reason enterprises years which was these
stories were after recent Foundation
started we actually had three paid staff
me and Marty Japan and the office
manager yeah 15 years into a publication
right as montebello 30 during during the
Santa Barbara years whatever his reason
enterprises just the partnership ran it
as a hobby business none of us getting
paid we had always somebody as an office
manager was getting a salaries obviously
only payroll and you all have seven
times we all had a full-time jobs yeah
yeah how did how did you survive I mean
that's it and what would like some of
the what was some of the biggest things
to go you from 400 circulation well
drink direct mail marketing i mean the
very first thing we did after after
buying the rights from lani Friedlander
actually we took the liability off his
hands because he had 400 subscriptions
to fullfillment was out of money so our
business plans was based on direct mail
marketing and the key initial success
the first thing we did before printing
an issue was to print a print up a
direct mail package and find a list to
mail it to that we thought would pay off
and we persuaded nathaniel branden who
at that time had broken with i & R and
only a few years before he had a mailing
list of book buyers Objectivist book
buyers and we persuaded him to let us
test his list but we had to remember
this we had to sign a statement promise
of pledging that we are not anarchists
and did not believe in overthrowing the
government
I was always actually the limited
government person and I'm still so i am
not an anarchist never been then and i
had no problem going along with that but
you know signing pledges not exactly my
every penny we had went into that
initial mailing to like 5,000 of the
name of the 20 or five or thirty
thousand or 4,000 names on the list and
it worked and if it hadn't worked
probably that would have been in didn't
have any other you put it down on red
yeah yeah yeahs with it and then we did
a follow on bill oh yeah the rest that
was the LE I'm a guy so she asleep right
right and this gave us such a feeling of
gratitude self gratitude were severely
pleased with ourselves and we really
knew her off to a bang and then after we
exhausted the academic associate list
where to go for more likely prospect Bob
lafave who is that a [ __ ] art college
and he was a self-proclaimed anarchist
who didn't even believe in use a force
for self-defense I'm not going to all
you can read of mind our days history of
libertarianism to read more about Bob
love faith but we used hit a bobble favs
list and that was a huge list so we knew
we were golden sitting so comfortably at
that point and then we mail the list and
because we against some well with the
academic associates list it led us to
the first real sound business lesson
that we ever learn and that was you
don't send out mailing to an entire list
without testing it we sent out to the
whole list was over a hundred thousand
causes a lot of money we got a lot of
hate mail back but there's a lot of fun
i took out the wrist in the mail we got
an F tidge do so we really almost crater
ya at that that was doubly second I was
a secondary surprises and and I'll say
one other thing which which it doesn't
go directly to that mailing but one of
the things that we envisions wouldn't
was not only coming for me laying
ourselves as kind of a counterpart of
National Review in Republic but also
there were a lot of ideological
magazines very small ones such as Lanny
had created but most of them are
sectarian magazines we
had a different view we weren't going to
represent the views of Bothwell fav the
views of mine ran the views of a
Rothbard ours was going to be a forum
open to any responsible broadchurch draw
a broad Church approach and so that was
really unique as far as we knew at the
time but it was part of our design that
was part of our grand scheme and so
we're sending little flavorless we
thought would be an easy piece fold in
well you know we just learned the hard
way we bounced back that crawled back
after that several people describe the
libertarian movement in the 1970s as a
thousand people selling magazines to
each other it was gonna hop up in the
last anybody assessments and they was
posted Monday but had come out about
eight or nine weeks apart so forth we
published a schedule every single month
we live by lived and died by that
schedule Bobby singers bob was a systems
engineer from MIT bob is the most
organized and care of you know the
careful planner it takes a system and
Bob is the master I've learned a lot
from Bob in this regard but the magazine
did come on time i would say fosters
can't do it alors can't do it why was
the keygen take this philosopher but I
want to ask you something when did the
idea of doing these interviews with
prominent libertarians become a sort of
a guiding well hand for us I don't know
is it it worked out oh yeah work out
very well and we were doing those even
in the reason enterprises here's to some
extent and run urania you did little
Brandon if I was the first one now there
was some embarrassment to that because I
did an interview with Brandon which then
Brandon completely rewrote and the only
way we could publish it and we were on
deadline and we couldn't do anything and
Brandon put us through this real hell
journalist akele difficulty also i mean
we also had I mean we had more mailing
scheduled of using that interview
because this was big news that we had an
exclusive in yahoo his first public
statements of the split with i right
that's
and so in turn had very interesting
published today then later we did
another interview with another
psychologist named Thomas sauce and he
do rewrote everything what is this with
these psychologists Hayek great no hi it
was great Friedman was great you know
almost everybody else yeah laid by the
idea of this was with playboy interviews
as as a feature that would become known
right as a trademark thing of reason no
none of these other magazines had done
interviews and I thought these
interviews Ronald Reagan the famous
quote uh ya know the Rotarians missed
the heart and soul every test we did
that just their his office on the
boulevard on one of the early another
aspect of the interviews other than the
zazz interview and the Brandon interview
most of the early interviews were merely
transcribed we didn't even think of all
the typos or misstatements we just ran
them we didn't really edit them and you
look back now it is read the early
interview is there correct I remember
the time cuz you know I've been a
knitter the N while our view we didn't
you know you Yost and edited for clarity
for expression but we felt an interview
was the person's language and we ran
though made of a current and so with
those two exceptions are mentioned yeah
the rule was we ran the interview just
the way with and we did some very good
interviews with Yale brausen with Bill
niskanen you know just it's a bunch of
fairly prominent people who and they
were very willing we have to grant that
they were very supportive is hard to
divert never not a big deal yet yeah we
had one historic interview about 1972
with the first time we interview two
people simultaneously was Murray
Rothbard Leonard leo oh that's
interviewed in my living room after
dinner we had a lot of wine there was a
period of time in the interview that
most people never detect where Leonard
says nothing when the question is
addressed in banbury answered when
Leonard world woke up after that period
beautiful Virginia you had a journalism
career and then you came to reason after
that what was your kind of assessment of
where the magazine was compared to the
opinion magazines at the time or what
was your kind of a feeling once you grew
up from your third grader ones do hey I
was in college I was in third grade when
it started yeah um well so I could it
would be something of an exaggeration
say I had in journalism career before I
get it inclination I was 26 so you know
although my journalism career had
started you know I guess it's an intern
between my junior years college I hadn't
you know didn't have lots of experience
um but I had good really good experience
at really good publications I came to
reason from ink and before that I had
worked in the now-defunct Philadelphia
Bureau of the wall street journal as a
reporter um it was interesting what
happened I'm does so one of the things
my husband to this day teases me about
is reading bulletin boards and back in
the day I used to also be classified ads
back when there were classified ads
actually I read them craigslist 20 but
um and so Steve had gotten a job at UCLA
and we were planning to move to LA and I
had worked out this deal with my editor
Inc to work half time for the magazine
and freelance half time because much as
I like writing about small business I
wanted to have freedom to write about
other things too um and then one day I
got the issue of reason and there's this
ad looking for an assistant editor and
lo and behold don't leave me
actually Stephen had an interview at
UCSB and I've got an offer there and I
thought wow he gets this job at UCSB
maybe I can work for a reason everything
you know everything my life like works
out well uh so so I applied for the job
and and you know sending my resume clips
to Marty because in fact one of the
things I knew from being a professional
journalist is right to the managing
editor actually she was I guess Eric
Marty I must have said that's right i
guess because eric was it anyway and I
came in and did an interview and this
being reason I also took a test lot of
pests in my life I had a test involved
you know writing a trend store a little
you know front of the book trend story
which I done for two years of inks are
really good at that editing a story
there was proof reading test I can't
remember it was for things that you have
to do in the job um and which by the way
is what a lot of research now says this
is how people should hire it's not how
they do hire but how I should hire the
Bob figure to help I so I came to reason
and one of the things I already knew
coming to reason because I had briefly
um had some interaction with Adam
Meyerson who would that I've mind you
from the journal who was at policy
review was that I knew that the articles
would be terrible coming in that
basically unlike the world which I was
coming from where articles were
basically pretty good and then the
editor made them better I knew that at
this magazine ninety percent of articles
would be really problematic ninety
percent is probably too high but a
really large number would not be to
professional standards and that the
staff the reason reason was as good as
it was was that the editors on the
reason staff were fixing things and I
actually kind of kind of knew that
coming in um but it was you know it's
kind of an adventure because the other
thing about it was everybody had just
moved from LA so everybody was new in LA
not just know
and we also had adopted one at the very
earliest very earliest desktop
publishing systems which did not have
WYSIWYG it's like 86 86 was the summer
of 86 we had this desktop publishing
system which was basically like writing
an HTML and it was almost it was very
very similar look very very similar to
HTML code and um and then in order to
see whether the thing the story was
formatted right you actually had
ascended out to the expensive place with
a silver bill and get it back and then
you know discovered that you had you
know mrs. you missed a code and
everything was a bold face or something
um and we were running off of an IBM XT
wallach alone but an xt which was very
primitive machine oh one step up from
the original PC then there was the big
advance where we got the 80 which was
the took 286 a slightly more powerful
machine and then we could use wysiwyg
and so then I would be Steve and I see
would like hang out with me and I would
be at the at the magazine with Nanette
Campbell who was the production manager
and we would be there like three o'clock
in the morning debugging code oh you
know and I was really either I was
really issued because I was really
interested the idea of thinking like a
computer but you can't do now unless
yeah you know I understand my computer
it's like voodoo you know it's magic it
does thanks for him is written but
reason my back then you could catch up
and so this was but it was kind of
adventure I mean I was 26 years old and
doing something new and working for a
cause that I believed in and having like
a great experience instead of being in a
medium size or before that large
bureaucratic organism Jenny did you know
that we were early users of the IBM
compositor which was an earlier version
pre HTML pre what you had when you moved
up oh yeah but we were able to have
really professional-looking
graphics we got we paid funding for
outside illustrators and land we try to
keep up landing at extraordinary sense
of graphic design and layout but we if
you go back to the early issues and we
did our own little improvements and
redesigns I'm not saying we were as good
as it god but we used into a paste up
every month whereas Sunday we did it
mostly in Los Angeles now different
venues but sometimes we just rented they
like an office services a secretarial
supply place he was on the way to use on
the weekend just to come at three am and
and so we knew what it was like we did
our own all the editors were there to
paste up on a light table and you know
most restaurants were closed in that
area there was nothing there was I guess
there was mcdonalds closed we never went
to but John hospice was one of her early
inspirations because John happened to be
before he died John was a great phosphor
and he was the head of the philosophy
department USC for a while and ran for
president as the Libertarian Party
candidate and I think most of us I sir
they campaigned in voted form but the
John was a great cook and he made these
extraordinary stews and soups soups and
he helped nourishes us physically and
mentally and spiritually to help us get
those magazines out and that was a great
day I must have come this close two
intersecting with their universe because
right as they were moving down from
state street around Santa Barbara to LA
I was going to UC Santa Barbara I got
that job it as a student but man then I
worked as doing typesetting for two
years and I actually know the systems
that you're talking about and made the
transition from putting the the film
into going to a desktop eter wins I
would never you have it sure to learn
about pace dogs do we did we do at all
we didn't learn that from a student at
USC was doing a sort of a libertarian
underground campus newspaper that they
produce and that he introduces to a
printer reduces the typesetters
basically taught us about paced up and
so forth but you make you mean I notice
by the way that
professional art director and a
professional production manager who were
very very young I mean you know they
didn't have a lot really was i'm like
the only very very very young people but
but they were people who knew about
these things it wasn't but i'm talking
about yeah but we're not quitting say
which makes that advanced a quick detail
matt matt said that we move from state
street los angeles we move from state
street in santa barbara the garden
street I just think about that promote
um I want to let me just say that you
may have noticed that past 86 I've sort
of fell out of the picture partly
because I went to teach in Europe and I
no longer kind of was useful to reason
at the time although I would
occasionally send in a column or
something maybe even do an interview but
you know there are people who are fairly
powerful influences at the beginning and
then not so much later you know and this
isn't many other endeavors that happens
i was there at the very beginning and
i'm very proud of what i contributed
then but i can't say that i was
sustaining them much later right what
you're quoted in the current issue
that's right I came as a surprise I want
to get your take on sort of broader
libertarian things before we open it up
to the audience here and then close it
off also for the internet but you were
there at the sort of beginning of the
modern libertarian movement let's say
and reason was part of that the LP which
started in 1971 how do you look at you
know the progress of that thing from
those days the early days of reason to
2013 well thanks to reason and its
editors and its staff we've always had a
sort of I hate to use that term because
it's sort of corrupted these days but we
had a modest tone and reason we were
never harsh we were never angry we
tended to discuss things we try to live
up to the title reason
I mean we took it seriously even though
we also had a lot of fun there was an
idea that it would be this is a hope
more than an idea that if we did that if
we kept a reasonable tone a civil tongue
we'd make more progress unfortunately it
takes two to tango Manny well I think I
go back to early issues of reason I find
things there that I can't put down
there's some great articles we I think
we've had a tremendous impact on helping
shape and guide the libertarian
consciousness in a rational direction
and I I can look back at edith efrain
was when the great order authors who
certainly gave us articles that didn't
eat heavy editing she was a great
professional officer on another issue
but she gave rise by the way to our logo
or slogan now which we used i think has
had a huge impact widely emulated and
sometimes copied free minds and free
markets came from a title that we had
put on it was a variation titled for an
early eat a different story edith
everyone wrote a piece that Clarence
Thomas told me he thought was the best
piece he had seen about the his
experience his ordeal in the the hearing
zones nomination for his report now I've
read Virginia had a piece Virginia and
Lynn bolted great pieces oncology on
Earth Day issues and Virginia's piece I
think was yours not lens of maybe Lynn's
Carla by think was yours Green Road to
Serfdom yeah that was it's a seminal
piece it's an extraordinary piece about
how the left lost out in the quest to
get everybody under socialism because
ideologically people rejected it but if
instead of saying you want to take over
all the means of you know the
means of production instead of saying
that you're going to protect mother
earth it was a lot more saleable and we
really about the left I have to disagree
with you well we have talked about this
afterwards but i think it was me what
call the future as enemies that's sort
of led to that the future these enemies
is also anyway great great pieces that
we hired well reasons some big more came
out of hoof you hope that reason but
anyway i think we've had a very
significant impact yeah i think the
magazine and and foundations public
policy were both have really made
libertarian the concept libertarian
respectable what brought it into the
mainstream it's not it's stuff so it's
not really fringe anymore I mean it's
used as a common phrase to describe a
point of view that has adherence in
Congress that has you know it here it's
in the media john stossel drew carey
this is a recognized thing and we played
a very big party and almost all of us
had reason have managed to get on fox in
one capacity or over the last three
years or so right have you been on there
not not directly interviewed but i but i
was part of the audience of what I'm
virginia long long sweep of arc of
libertarianism reasons intersection with
its we all know that obviously the
magazine's gone downhill since possible
but beyond that well i would say that
the big
the bigs get to me what was important in
my life which is not necessarily the
same as the big sweep of libertarianism
was a reason of course and also a lot of
the work that was done in the Academy
particularly at the university of
chicago and i think that that whether
you're talking about milton friedman are
wrong KO's who in a recent interview
said he wasn't a libertarian um which is
partly because the word libertarian has
some negative baggage as well as he
wasn't a libertarian I thought it was
not he was not he was not he's free
market but not oh yeah um ah but he
wasn't he wasn't saying I'm not a
libertarian because you know I'm for
drug laws he was saying because my my
picture of a libertarian is very narrow
but I was a fashion see as because
because he's really more in what I would
call the classical liberal tradition um
which is very imperious and what it's
called libertarianism tends to be very
deductive 'used and not so empiricist
and I'm an empiricist so I'm sort of
uncomfortable answering this question
because to me the people who are the
Titans in my you know it really
influencing me and I think in
influencing the world or these very
empirically oriented a highly rigorous
academics social scientists all and that
is not a few that makes friends
libertarian movement you see that their
work or the tradition of their work is
it on the decline is it is it wider well
I think it's had some really profound
and lasting effects but um in some ways
they haven't reproduced themselves I
mean they did actually but it things
have gone in other directions and more
recent years and you know I'm sure tibor
you would sit inspect your every because
every academic says this you know this
fields get narrower and narrower and
more and more specialized over time so
that and you know
we're in I know that the what you're
supposed to say now is we're in a
libertarian moment but we're also in the
opposite which is because the financial
crisis there's a lot of feeling that you
know only the state can intervene and do
these things and you know never mind
nobody knows anything about
macroeconomics in mind yeah it was like
we know more than maybe 50 years ago a
little bit but there's that's like
saying nobody knows anything about
astrology phony feel many none of us
will testified you that they do it
because they're Dean's require them to
do it well I wouldn't go that far but oh
come on but but it may be a little bit
more like you know alchemy which led to
chemistry or something which had some
truths and some real stuff going on but
there was a lot of you know so you know
I I think that there is in the American
culture a very strong libertarian streak
it's not the only strong streak in
American culture there's some competing
one some of them within the same brain
of the same person and you know and
things ebb and flow but the important
thing is you know sort of thinking
through the ideas and promoting the
ideas so that when the moment is right
people are ready for them so let's just
say in fairness that there is the
Austrian influence as well she's not
very empiricist you would grant that
well i would say that there's a there is
that high x work has a kind of
empiricism but it's not anywhere like
gary becker or these guys it's much more
of a eclectic view which draws on all
meth illogical traditions and i think
that im here IM fluss by Hayek as well
then I think at the reason foundation
including Reason magazine we draw on
most stress
eleuterio yeah you know I think that's
true and I think that's something they
guess man you were talking about that
early on and and that is something I
think that's important about the
magazine yeah and that's why it has been
an important institution because it it
was this kind of Big Ten yeah are you in
anything that promotes civil discourse
you know I mean even across the
methodological divides there is some
good discussions maybe not academic
discussions but certainly intellectual
discourse and that's been that's been a
trademark I just want to say that along
with the generation that we wrote for in
there read our magazine there are things
going on outside the walls of reason and
they included building Friedman's
writing for Newsweek may also been
writing free to choose of the TV on the
PBS there were there were sessions in
San Diego and others that people came to
view as a group free to choose you we
had no questions and answers afterwards
and there were other things but rothbard
was writing Mises was no kind of in his
senior years but I had that benefit of
setting with meeses when i was in nyu
law school and he was teaching the
business school then but we knew a lot
of these people hike was it universe
cago when i was there and so there was a
lot of their work going on
simultaneously or could have the same
concurrently with us and that he has
meant we weren't the only voice out
there and the question is is there is
this a libertarian age was there one
well the history of the old right or the
history of classical liberalism with
history of the real leading exponents of
limited government constitutionalist
approach now the Tea Party there there's
been a lot of strains of libertarianism
I for one think the Tea Party is one of
the greatest things now I think that's
brought on largely not from the banking
crisis the financial crisis but the
overreach of the Obama
administration and Obama this is such a
super smooth salesman he's got the wool
pulled over a lot of people's eyes but
Obama's overreaching and his arrogance
has given rise now in this massively the
high taxes the massive spending
Obamacare has given rise to the Tea
Party which flourishes on learning
things at taking ideas seriously the
Constitution reason has got a big
following among tea party people and so
I think it's the give and take that's
going on that we are playing a very
robust role in but the movement is much
large the federal societies the other
group other no Kato is there a lot of
other organizations I want to cut off
Virginia no I wanted to stop the web
streams who can get answers or questions
from the audience I'm sure there's some
people dying to to pick some brains up
here before that you wanted to make up I
was just holla dick Torian well I was
just gonna say that part of what reason
does and has done throughout its history
is to be this or broker of ideas I mean
I describe my work that I do now is
intellectual arbitrage and and that's
sort of what reason does is it takes you
know takes the ideas of a hayek or a
free men and and you know makes them
understandable and popular and use a
storytelling techniques and techniques
of journalism which are not necessarily
the techniques of academia and also in
doing that this empiricism is relevant
because even if you're trying to
illustrate something that comes from
somebody who's not particularly
empiricist if you're doing journalism
you're going to happen to you you write
out Marshall the other going to have to
connect with the real world oh that's
sort of in the nature of our discipline
if you want to think of it as a
discipline and so I think that's a role
that reason has always played throughout
its really in the DNA yeah all right
won't say thank you to the web folks
watching at home and now we're really in
a party so
do we have a Phil Donahue memorial
microphone
yep